Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Lauren
Boebert feud has exploded. It is a pretty
bonkers what we're about to talk about. So, of
course, Marjorie Taylor GREENE, Lauren Boebert,
two of the most radical, most extreme MAGA
Republicans. Super detached from reality,
super anti-democratic, super dangerous.
But despite being similar in those ways,
apparently personally, they very much despise one
another. And we talked about in the last segment
the fact that Lauren Boebert is now trying to
impeach Joe Biden. And it seems based on that
and some other things they have built up,
but that has been or that is for this story,
kind of the spark. Marjorie Taylor
GREENE is very upset with Lauren Boebert
because she feels like Lauren Boebert is
copying her or taking her attention. Very
strange. And this built to reportedly a moment
of Marjorie Taylor GREENE calling Lauren Boebert
as The Daily Beast. Right. And actually, I'm
trying to think about the the radio and television
affiliates of the do pack, which show I'll just
say for this story, little B-word. Okay. I think
you can figure out what that is. This is from The
Daily Beast. Marjorie Taylor GREENE calls Bieber
a little bee on the House floor. The messy feud
between two of MAGA World's biggest stars burst
into public view on Wednesday when Representative
Marjorie Taylor GREENE called Representative
Lauren Boebert a little beat to her face on the
floor of the House U.S. House of Representatives.
The angry exchange came as the two lawmakers have
been swiping at each other over their competing.
This is so they're competing resolutions to
impeach President Joe Biden. I want to impeach
Biden. I want to be divided. But tensions came
to a head on Wednesday after Boebert leveraged
a procedural tool to force a vote on her own
impeachment resolution. We talked about that in
the last segment within days, undercutting GREENE,
who had offered her own resolution, but not with
the procedural advantages of forcing a vote. Look
at yourself, Maja. Look at yourself in the mirror.
GREENE apparently cursed out Boebert while the
House was voting Wednesday afternoon as the two
spoke in a center aisle. We'll look at this video
in a moment of the House floor. Part of their
interaction was captured on C-SPAN's cameras.
According to sources that saw the exchange and
a third familiar with the matter, the back and
forth began when Boebert approached GREENE,
then seated in the chamber and confronted her over
statement You made about me publicly, all three of
the sources said. Green called Boebert a B, one
of the source said. Green called her a little
B, so you can take your pick on which one you
think, actually. Happened. Not a really big
difference to me. Apparently, Green said that
Boebert copied her articles of impeachment, but
Boebert denies that. So that is as
immature and as MAGA GOP as it gets.
And here's the video. There is no audio of
them saying this, but we can just imagine.
Speaker 4: Thank you conversations
to the back off the floor.
For what purpose does the gentlewoman.
Speaker 3: Order, please.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 4:
For what purpose does the
gentlewoman from Florida. Mrs. Loana.
Speaker 1: I'll mute the video, but you can
see it seems somewhat heated just by what
you're watching on screen. But with the
added context of what is being reported,
what a moment. And you combine that with what we
saw. During the speaker vote where Matt Gaetz was
lunged at by another member. And there there's
just chaos within this MAGA GOP. And is that
necessarily a reflection of how outrageous their
policy positions and rhetoric otherwise are? No,
but it is interesting that the party with the most
dangerous views also happens to be a chaotic mess
with low character interpersonally. It just so
happens, and I think those things tend to coincide
that that's the characteristic of this movement
as well. You could never imagine with all the
differences Democrats will have. You remember,
there was a big divide between Joe Manchin and
progressive Democrats during kind of the build
back better debate era. And you can never imagine
something like that happening. There's a level
of seriousness, professionalism and maturity
within the Democratic Party that apparently is
just completely evaporating within the Republican
Party. Pretty wild. And it's all over their
argument over who should get the attention,
I guess, for impeaching Joe Biden. Make sure
you are subscribed to my YouTube channel
if you want to get more of what you're
getting today. Luke Beasley on YouTube